[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 votre
émission pour bien démarrer la soirée
dans les Yvelines avec au programme de
l'actualité des infos pratiques et des
idées de sortie voici le programme de ce
7 novembre
[Musique]
plaisir compte désormais une deuxième
main la maison d'assistant maternelle
les petits yogi a été inaugurés
officiellement ce matin dans le quartier
des Gâtines cette structure peut
accueillir jusqu'à 16 enfants parmi les
espaces une pièce dédiée à l'éveil
sensorielle et à la relaxation pour la
pratique du yoga des tout-petits Sabine
Batista et Stéphanie Paulin président et
co-fondatrice du lieu sont nos invités
elle a pour but de sensibiliser les
jeunes à la citoyenneté l'association
pharmacie citoyen reprend ses activités
après une période de mise en sommeil
pendant les vacances de la Toussaint un
voyage a notamment été organisé à Verdun
au Mémorial de la Première Guerre
mondiale on en parle avec le président
de pharmacie citoyens Mustapha lahbaoui
et puis nos yvelinois Louis Burton et
Eric Bellion devront patienter encore un
peu la Route du Rhum cette course de
voile transatlantique en solitaire a été
décalé à mercredi en raison et des
conditions de météos le départ de cette
course a été décalé à mercredi les
autres résultats sports du week-end à
suivre dans cette édition nous
reviendrons également sur la mise à pied
vous le voyez et de l'entraîneur du
Football Club de Versailles Youssef
avec des journalistes de la rédaction de
TV 78 en plateau il y en a un qui est
avec moi déjà c'est Michael ennemi Doro
bonsoir bonsoir journaliste sport et
avec vous on va parler sport de quoi on
parlera tout à l'heure on parlera du
tirage au sort de la Ligue des Champions
les 8e de finale de Paris qui va
affronter le Bayern Munich on va parler
évidemment de cette Route du Rhum et de
ce programme un peu décalé il devait
partir le dimanche il part finalement le
mercredi on reviendra aussi sur le match
de plaisir en fédéral 2 ce week-end et
ce sera tout à l'heure dans le 7 8 des
invités également dans cette émission à
ma gauche il y a Sabine Batista et
Stéphanie Paulin bonsoir donc Sabine
Batista Stéphanie Paulin qui est sur la
gauche de ces places invitées alors
respectivement je vous présente
présidente Sabine Batista et
cofondatrice pour Stéphanie Paulin des
petits yogi alors je le disais en
sommaire c'est la nouvelle maison
d'assistant maternelle qui a ouvert à
plaisir elle a ouvert à la mi-octobre a
été inaugurée ce lundi matin et
déjà une première question après en
bulle qu'est-ce qu'une maison
d'assistant maternelle c'est une
solution complémentaire finalement dans
les solutions de garde qui existent qui
s'offrent aux parents
Sabine déjà tout d'abord merci de cette
invitation sur le plateau pour pouvoir
en parler oui effectivement c'est un
complément de mode d'accueil vous avez
les crèches et micro-crèche les
assistantes maternelles et nous nous
sommes entre les deux c'est à dire que
nous avons une structure qui peut
accueillir ces enfants et quatre
professionnels de la petite enfance pour
pouvoir justement pratiquer notre
profession en sécurité et toutes
bienveillance et vous me disiez
Stéphanie poulain ce qui est apprécié
par les parents c'est justement cet
entre-deux c'est ça aussi
familial de l'assistante maternelle et
le semi collectivité donc c'est vrai
qu'on est vraiment entre les deux et les
parents c'est ce qui recherchent aussi
c'est vraiment ce qui recherche
dans un instant plateau également
Mustapha Larbaoui bonsoir Mustapha
bonsoir président de l'association
format citoyen vous êtes également
système municipal de la ville de Trappes
alors je rappelle que Pharma citoyen
c'est une association qui sensibilise
les jeunes de CM2 à la citoyenneté avec
de nombreuses sorties notamment parmi
les actions et à la reprise ses
activités je le disais en titre après
une période de mise en sommeil et qui a
débuté durant la campagne des élections
municipales en 2021 pour vous étiez
candidat ça vous manquait le terrain
associatif terriblement j'en viens j'en
ai sur fait depuis l'âge de quasiment 17
18 ans j'en ai toujours fait et j'étais
en sommeil avant de me lancer sur la
municipale pas pendant mais avant et
puis il m'a fallu un peu de temps le
temps de relancer tout ça et c'est
maintenant reparti et c'est pas une de
mes deux sorties qui ont été faites
pendant les vacances de la Toussaint
mais on va en faire beaucoup plus parce
qu'on a étendre le champ d'action de
pharmacie citoyen non plus à la ville de
Trappes où j'avais commencé mais sur
l'agglo avec de nouveaux clubs
partenaires on aura l'occasion d'en
parler dans un instant mais tout de
suite coup d'oeil à votre météo de
demain
[Musique]
ce mardi à 8 novembre jour de la saint
Geoffroy il y aura des éclaircies dans
la matinée comptait 12 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et Versailles 11
degrés à Rambouillet l'après-midi il
pourrait y avoir quelques averses côté
température 14 degrés à Rambouillet 15
degrés à Versailles ou dans et
Mantes-la-Jolie
[Musique]
avant de parler de ces sujets avec nos
invités tous ces sujets un petit point
sur les informations du jour et dans les
Yvelines c'est avec Céline Charles qui
nous a rejoint au plateau bonsoir de la
rédaction de TV 78 et on commence avec
cette réouverture qui était attendue
mais qui a été une nouvelle fois
retardée malheureusement c'est celle de
l'accueil des urgences pédiatriques de
l'hôpital de Poissy oui effectivement
l'accueil des urgences pédiatriques
restera fermée pour une durée
indéterminée à l'hôpital de Poissy une
fermeture prononcée le 21 octobre pour
cause de pénurie de médecins pédiatre
conséquences pas d'accueil direct les
parents des patients sont invités à
contacter directement le 15 le SAMU
décidera de l'orientation la plus
adaptée en fonction de l'état de santé
de l'enfant par exemple vers des maisons
médicales de garde ou d'autres hôpitaux
du secteur de nouveaux médecins sont
activement recherchés par l'hôpital pour
établir la situation on vient également
avec vous sur cette action menée à
Versailles samedi par des militants de
l'ONG Greenpeace et oui une vingtaine de
militants Greenpeace du groupe local de
Versailles ont mené une opération pour
sensibiliser à la sobriété éner
l'objectif était d'alerter sur la
consommation électrique et le gaspillage
d'énergie au travers de panneaux
lumineux publicitaires implantés sur la
voie publique les militants recouvert 25
panneaux publicitaires d'une affiche
dénonçant l'absurdité des panneaux
éclairés toute la nuit en période bien
sûr de sobriété énergétique demander aux
citoyens le chiffre du jour enchaîner le
chiffre du jour c'est -15% c'est le
pourcentage minimum que soit réalisé la
ville de Montigny-le-Bretonneux cet
hiver sur la consommation de gaz et
d'électricité dans les bâtiments
communaux la ville anticipée une
situation très compliquée avec la hausse
des prix cet hiver en réduisant la plage
horaire de certains espaces de loisirs
le cinéma Jacques Brel est notamment
concerné il proposera des séances
uniquement le week-end du vendredi au
dimanche le centre aqualitique du lac
qui est l'équipement le plus énergivor
du territoire se rend quand en lui
fermer tous les dimanches les décisions
peuvent être bien sûr réajustées en
fonction des besoins dans les mois à
venir l'image du jour avec une nouveauté
celle d'un premier marché qui s'est tenu
samedi à Voisins-le-Bretonneux oui
fruits et légumes pas un traiteur ou
encore poulet fermier lévisinois et
vicinoises attendaient et l'ont obtenu
ils ont désormais leur marché le samedi
matin la ville a passé une en accord
avec l'entreprise simplicité pour
proposer un marché alimentaire chaque
samedi matin pendant un an une douzaine
d'expositions seront présents le marché
sera sur le parking de la Poste à côté
de la mairie
mettre en avant la montée en puissance
d'une petite troupe de théâtre
versaillaise oui c'est une petite troupe
qui prend du galon maintenant la troupe
en chantier compagnie de théâtre amateur
à Versailles fondées en 2014 a reçu le
prix de la Tour d'Argent au concours
national de théâtre amateurs festa 2022
confronté à une vingtaine de troupes le
4 novembre dernier c'est leur pièce 1494
jours une histoire d'amour burlex
burlesque et dramatique qui a séduit le
jury une pièce écrite par
pierre-henriette créateur et metteur en
scène de la troupe et on reste à
Versailles pour terminer avec cette
information révélée ce matin Youssef
chibi n'est plus l'entraîneur du
Football Club de Versailles du moins
pour le moment la nouvelle est tombée ce
lundi 7 novembre le club l'a annoncé
lors communiquer officielle Youssef
chibi a été mise à pied à titre
conservatoire sans préciser les raisons
de cette mise à pied coach de l'équipe
depuis juillet 2014 et artisans de la
progression du club jusqu'en National 1
il avait aussi emmené le club en
demi-finale de la Coupe de France
l'année dernière Vincent et human
manager de l'équipe est l'ensemble du
staff actuel prince en charge l'équipe
pour la réception du Stade briochin ce
vendredi 11 novembre non pas de lien
établi pour le moment mais on rappelle
que Youssef chibi avait été visé en été
à l'été dernier par une enquête pour
atteinte de l'intimité de la vie privée
il y avait une plainte à une plainte qui
avait été déposée par une jeune femme
Youssef chibi qui a été auditionné dans
le cadre de cette affaire mais pas mise
en examen merci Céline et d'ailleurs
ainsi vous aussi vous êtes témoin d'une
information vous souhaitez partager d'un
fait près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
le faire sur nos réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news dans
l'actualité du jour on en parlait en
début d'émission c'est l'inauguration
d'une deuxième maison d'assistant
maternelle à plaisir les petits yogi qui
ont ouvert depuis la mi-octobre dans le
quartier des Gatines l'inauguration je
le disais a eu lieu ce matin alors en
chiffres quelques chiffres pour
présenter la structure elle pour
accueillir jusqu'à 16 enfants dans un
espace de 144 mètres carrés avant d'en
parler avec vous à Sabine Baptista et
Stéphanie poulain je vous propose de
regarder cette interview collecté ce
matin sur place lors de l'inauguration
et une interview de la mère de plaisir
Joséphine Coleman berger réalisé par
Gabriel Gontier et Régine raleche
[Musique]
sont des assistantes maternelles
libérales qui se regroupent pour pouvoir
se mettre ensemble et créer un projet
autour d'un lieu pour accueillir des
enfants comme quand c'était dans leur
propre maison mais je dirais autour d'un
projet comme celui-ci par exemple qui
est un projet très spécifique
quand des assistantes maternelles
veulent sortir de chez elle pour faire
exactement le même travail de proximité
avec les parents et bien le se regroupe
à deux ou à 3 selon les locaux possibles
pour créer une MAM qui est quelque chose
de tout à fait je dirais intermédiaire
entre l'assistante maternelle à domicile
et la crèche c'est un intermédiaire
elles disent que la proximité qu'elles
ont quand elles sont assistantes
maternelle libérale c'est justement
cette proximité avec les parents et
c'est ce qu'elles veulent recréer ici
puisque les parents ne sont pas
seulement des personnes qui viennent
confier leur enfant mais ces personnes
qui sont actives également à l'intérieur
de la MAM puisque elle nous disait tout
à l'heure que il y avait des activités
qui est faite qui étaient faites
justement avec les parents
la Villa investi plus de 140 000 euros
pour pouvoir mettre à disposition ce
lieu pour ces personnes et on souhaite
bien sûr en développer d'autres sur
l'ensemble de la collectivité
et on les a vu sur ces dernières images
Sabine Baptiste à président des petits
yogi et Stéphanie Paulin co-fondatrice
de lieu sont avec nous en plateau ça a
été dit dans cette interview express la
structure a été le renouvellement de
cette rupture était entièrement financée
par la commune de plaisir qui est aussi
mis les locaux à disposition comment ça
s'est passé justement cette démarche
c'est vous qui êtes allé voir la mairie
de plaisir pour monter ce projet
Stéphanie Paulin oui on avait créé le
projet toutes les deux et en fait on
s'est rapproché de la ville de plaisir
qui m'avait déjà ouvert une première
maison d'assistante maternelle il y
avait comme objectif d'en ouvrir une
deuxième notre projet il a plu à la
ville de plaisir donc effectivement on a
on est venu sur la ville de plaisir
alors que nous même nous sommes de
Montigny qui avait ouvert du côté du
quartier du valibout et cette fois-ci
c'est dans le quartier des Gatines
pourquoi fallait-il cette structure pour
pour la commune de plaisir pourquoi
c'était intéressant justement d'ouvrir
ce cette nouvelle maison d'assistant
maternel
parce que les plaisirs rois et les
plaisirs roses
en avait besoin était dans cette attente
là c'était une demande une demande forte
également de
la mairie voilà d'avoir cette ouverture
d'esprit et puis les gatine c'est un
quartier qui se rajeunit et donc il y a
beaucoup de construction et de jeunes
familles qui s'y installe donc voilà
c'était un bon compromis c'était c'était
un engagement fort en fait de la ville
de voilà de d'être mise en avant et de
dire voilà nous on y croit on sait que
ça ça fonctionne les parents voilà se
sentent se sentent bien dans cette
structure voilà c'est vraiment des
structures qui parlent c'est pas
l'assistante maternelle chez elle c'est
pas la crèche voilà c'est en fait c'est
un mode d'accueil qui correspond à des
familles chacun peut retrouver voilà ils
ont le choix
finalement entre l'accueil collectif
familial cette maison pour accueillir
jusqu'à 16 enfants aujourd'hui toutes
les places sont prises où il reste
encore des plages justement pour les
familles plaisiroises il reste encore
des places pour les familles
plaisiroises sur l'année 2023 comment ça
se passe concrètement et elles viennent
directement sur place elles prennent
contact avec la mairie pour avoir cette
solution par la mairie de plaisir oui et
nous après on reçoit les parents sur la
MAM et on va accueillir courant 2023
deux autres collègues qui elles aussi
auront des places disponibles RPE juste
pour préciser
aussi il y a une pièce qui est dédiée à
l'éveil sensorielle ça c'est aussi
quelque chose d'assez original et à la
relaxation pour la pratique du yoga des
tout-petits pourquoi c'est intéressant
et pourquoi c'est ça peut être une bonne
chose pour les pour les petits justement
les initiés au yoga
Stéphanie proposait du yoga là où on
était avant dans l'association
d'assistante maternelle et on avait vu
les bienfaits en fait de cette pratique
et du coup pour ce connecter à ses
propres émotions on avait décidé de
justement de faire un programme par
rapport à tout ça parce qu'on avait vu
tout ça du plus jeune âge jusqu'à l'âge
de rentrée à l'école les enfants sont
beaucoup plus apaisés en moment de
familiarisation aussi ça permet de
baisser les angoisses et de pouvoir
aussi évoluer dans un monde où c'est
toujours plus plus du stress et eux ben
ils sont dans un cocon en fait ils se
reconnectent à leurs émotions nous on se
connecte à eux et ça ça permet aux
enfants de d'être beaucoup plus calme et
en fin de journée ou voilà une
frustration supplémentaire on est là on
les accompagne on se on se recentre en
fait c'est un moment pour ces enfants
justement ils vont évoluer très vite
c'est un moyen de les accompagner un
moyen différent un moyen intéressant
tout ça et donc la salle sensorielle est
très bien pour ça l'éveil des sens c'est
très important du coup on va on est là
pour les accompagner et puis pour
apprendre tout ça donc aujourd'hui il y
a cette nouvelle structure qui a ouvert
à plaisir depuis la mi-octobre est-ce
qu'il y a de nouvelles maisons
d'assistant maternelle qui pourrait
ouvrir aussi dans la ville prochainement
ils sont vraiment ouverts par rapport
aux maisons maternelles donc c'est vrai
que la ville de plaisir elle est elle
est innovatrice pour ça donc oui toutes
les assistantes maternelle qui ont ça à
cœur c'est vraiment un projet à poser et
elles ont elles savent ce qu'elles
veulent faire effectivement qu'elle se
rapproche de la ville de Plaisir voilà
c'est intéressant merci d'être venu en
parler en plateau à Stéphanie Paulin
Sabine bassista c'est vénipolin je
rappelle que vous êtes co-fondatrice des
petits yogi et Sabine cette étape
présidente de ce lieu les petits yogi
les petits yogi même qui ont ouvert à
plaisir depuis la nuit octobre et ce
matin il y avait donc l'inauguration
officielle de ce lieu merci d'être venu
en parler en plateau
et je me tourne vers notre autre invité
Mustapha Larbi oui je le disais tout à
l'heure président de format citoyens
alors cette association on disait avait
été mise en sommeil puisque entre temps
vous avez eu un engagement politique à
la ville de Trappes vous avez été élu
aux côtés d'autres Madness roux dans un
groupe d'opposition vous avez été élu
qu'on s'est municipal de la ville de
Trappes en 2020 dans le groupe
d'opposition dotman nasrow vous avez
depuis quitté vous nous disiez tout à
l'heure
ce qui vous manquait dans cet engagement
citoyen pourquoi il faut réinvestir
aujourd'hui pourquoi il faut la relancer
cette association alors d'abord ça s'est
arrêté avant les élections donc c'est
2019 ça vous a pas échappé qu'il y a une
pandémie qui fait que ça a d'autant plus
prise de temps pris de temps pour que ça
repartte et puis ensuite j'ai eu mes
propres affaires à régler puisque je
suis pharmacien également donc ici
et puisque vous parlez de l'engagement
politique
jusque tout le monde a bien compris que
mon engagement politique était un
engagement de rassemblement et non pas
de d'aller dans un sens politique pour
le quitter ensuite mais c'était un
rassemblement on va dire une opportunité
pour qu'on se rassemble sur un projet
politique sur les villes de train le
projet n'a pas abouti les Trappistes ont
choisi autrement depuis j'ai repris mon
indépendance on va dire politique et
donc l'idée majeure c'est que je ne
mélange pas tout simplement je crois que
ce que je déteste le plus justement dans
le monde des adultes c'est qu'on mélange
on va dans les associations faire de la
politique on va dans les associations
pour faire du business on va dans les
associations pour faire des choses qui
intéressent les adultes et là moi je
rejoins ce que ce que disent ces dames
puisqu'elle s'occupe d'enfants moi
j'interviens un peu plus tard que les
adultes s'occupent des enfants les
adultes s'occupent beaucoup trop
beaucoup trop des adultes et mon
pressentiment c'est qu'on va de plus en
plus vers une société où on s'occupe de
plus en plus d'adultes et on met de plus
en plus de moyens sur l'adulte alors on
va mettre de plus en plus de prison de
plus en plus de gardiens de prison de
plus en plus de juges de plus en plus de
policiers de plus en plus de gendarmes
on va vers une société on va aramer tout
le monde et la violence c'est de plus en
plus majeur et on y va de plus en plus
si on pouvait raisonner un peu avant
c'est-à-dire en restant sur les enfants
et mesdames je vous en remercie et quand
j'entends parler de yoga quand j'entends
parler de toutes ces notions qui font
que on apaise des enfants nous dans
notre association quand on faisait du
ramassage scolaire et qu'on aille
chercher des enfants à la sortie des
écoles c'était un moyen aussi de les
apaiser en faisant un goûter et de les
apaiser parce que dans les quartiers
parce que c'est un peu précisément les
quartiers dont on parle s'il y a une
notion importante qu'il faut régler dans
ces quartiers c'est ces notions de
concentration les membres dans nos
quartiers sont souvent déconcentrés il y
a tout le temps du bruit il y a tout le
temps de la c'est la promiscuité qui
fait qu'à un moment donné la décontra la
déconcentration est importante donc il
faut revenir vers la valeur simple
s'occuper des mômes mettre des moyens
sur les mômes et faire en sorte que ces
dames puissent travailler avec des
enfants et fassent passer vos messages
et vos méthodes que nous à notre niveau
justement et moi j'ai pris des CM2
pourquoi parce que le CM2 c'est
une classe charnière une classe majeure
et le programme est simple je colle au
programme d'histoire du CM2 Première
Guerre mondiale Seconde Guerre mondiale
l'industrialisation les valeurs on va
dire citoyenne au travers du Sénat et
des institutions c'est la citoyenneté ça
parle plus à beaucoup de jeunes
aujourd'hui ce mot citoyenneté je vous
mets au défi sur ce plateau demandez une
définition simple quand je regarde
citoyenneté et que je vais sur les
réseaux sociaux j'ai des rapports qui
sont faits par le Conseil d'État c'est
280 pages c'est compliqué d'expliquer
280 pages à nos mots donc on va vers des
notions simples des notions simples un
quand on voyage on voit des choses on
est sensib de sauge on va vers des vers
de la symbolique on écoute des gens dans
les musées qui vous disent des choses
importantes on voit des choses qui sont
prenantes donc oui le voyage qui
accompagne et qui illustre le programme
de CM2 et puis le CM2 c'est pas
simplement les guerres et tous les
notions les notions mémoriales mais
c'est également la construction de la
paix il y a rien de plus facile chez
l'être humain que de se sur la
gueule et qui est la guerre c'est
important de ne plus difficile
quand on a des gens comme ces dames qui
font des choses avec les enfants sur ces
notions que vous constatez que nos
adultes travaillent sur nos enfants et
tout le reste ça coûte des milliards
pour pas grand chose qu'on revient la
notion simple et ça coûte ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que aujourd'hui il
faut passer par le terrain associatif
pour faire passer ce genre de message la
politique ne sert plus à grand chose
politique je l'ai répété tout à l'heure
une parenthèse pour un pour un on va
dire pour quelque chose de plus
collectif droit de gauche sans religion
sans parti politique moi j'étais là
dedans et j'en suis sorti oui parce que
la politique est un vrai sujet pour moi
j'ai des subventions de la gauche j'ai
la droite sur le dos je vais prendre les
subventions de la droite j'ai la gauche
sur le dos je prends plus un centime de
subvention je vais chercher des
partenaires qui comprennent que ce pays
est en danger je vais chercher des
partenaires financiers mes propres font
et je mets de l'argent privé et croyez
moi que le budget qu'on met sur cette
sur la table pour notre projet et
colossal et il est apolitique et il est
sans l'argent des collectivités locales
parce que la France prend conscience
qu'il y a des choses à faire et les gens
participent à ces notions là et c'est un
engagement qui est 35 sortie par an 35
sorties par an avec plusieurs minibus
c'est les locations de minibus c'est de
l'essence cdplay des des des entrées
c'est beaucoup d'argent
mais c'est pas par les collectivités
locales c'est pas par le monde politique
et entre guillemets j'aimerais bien que
d'un seul coup on puisse se réunir une
bonne fois pour toi pour dire sur des
thèmes en tous les cas sur le thème de
l'enfant l'enfance ou les petits enfants
qu'on se met d'accord sur des projets
simples et là citoyenneté c'est à la
fois très compliqué et on peut faire des
choses beaucoup plus simple et c'est un
engagement qui est parti de la ville de
trappe on rappelle que vous avez été
pharmacien dans la ville vous avez été
président du club de football de trap et
vous êtes donc lancé cette association
format citoyen mais aujourd'hui ça
s'étend à d'autres villes il y a des
partenaires avec d'autres clubs de
football c'est des communes de foot et
on en a vu les on en a vu les
répercussions sur un club sur une 14 sur
14 années parce que l'éducatif c'est
long et je me suis rendu compte que ça
fonctionnait aujourd'hui je sors on va
dire de du périmètre des pharmacies
d'une part la politique d'autre part et
j'ai envie de l'étendre à d'autres clubs
et donc les partenaires en cours
notamment Guyancourt a signé plaisir à
signer et l'encours assigner incroyable
d'autres sont en attente j'attends la
réponse de Maurepas voisin et nos amis
mais je veux surtout remercier ses
présidents parce que c'est président ils
sont sur le terrain ils sont concurrents
ils cherchent des résultats mais par
contre sur ces notions là ils m'ont dit
oui sur ces notions là ils m'ont dit oui
voilà ces adultes que je veux remercier
voilà les vrais adultes qui s'occupent
de français
de nombreux de nombreuses actions il y a
le soutien scolaire forcément il y a
aussi toutes ces sorties donc vous
parliez eu des sorties pendant les
vacances de la Toussaint à Verdun allez
voir aussi au centre national minier
c'est ça le centre alors minier c'est
parce que c'est la réindustrialisation
ça fait partie du programme mais c'est
aussi tellement de gens à la prière qui
ont participé donc aux opérations dans
les mines mais c'est aussi beaucoup
d'émigrations qui sont venus travailler
dans ces mines et qui a participé
justement au mouvement migratoire qui
dit aussi quelque chose de l'Immigration
et de ce qu'on peut en dire aujourd'hui
donc il y a plein de choses à dire mais
on va également à Bruxelles au Parlement
européen on va également au Sénat à
l'Assemblée nationale on va au musée de
l'esclavage donc c'est le passé mais
c'est aussi présent
en fait c'est les horreurs de ce que
l'humanité c'est comprendre comment on a
pu
ses horreurs pour aussi on a pu
construire la paix quand la suite on en
sort par nos mômes si on s'en occupe
bien si les adultes que des adultes
pas gagné par contre si les adultes
voulaient mettre beaucoup moins de
moyens mais beaucoup plus d'efforts et
beaucoup plus d'énergie sur nos enfants
on y gagnerait franchement merci
Mustapha Larbaoui président de pharma
citoyens également conseiller municipal
de la ville de Trappes vous étiez
justement président pendant le longues
années de ce club de football de trap on
va parler sport à présent dans le 7 8
avec le retour de Michael Elmi Doro et
on connaît le prochain adversaire
Michael Dua Paris Saint-Germain en Ligue
des Champions le tirage au sort des
huitièmes de finale de la compétition
tant attendu avait lieu à la mi-journée
au siège de l'UEFA en Suisse et ce sera
un gros morceau pour les Parisiens le
Bayern Munich vainqueur à six reprises
de la Champions League les Bavarois
longs remporté en 2021 pour la dernière
fois c'était face au PSG en finale score
final 1 à 0 et 2 équipes se sont
affrontés à 11 reprises dans la
compétition et le bilan est à la faveur
des Parisiens s'y succès contre 5 pour
les Allemands pour ce huitième de finale
le match aller aura lieu le 14 février
prochain au Parc des Princes match
retour à l'alliance Arena de Munich le 7
mars le football en en reparle dans un
instant mais peut-être autour de cette
table je suis très mauvais je suis très
mauvais en pronostic mais on peut
demander où il va falloir bah oui moi
j'en fais pas passe pas ce niveau là moi
je suis à la machine dans le football
amateur je fais pas de pronostics à ce
niveau là c'est ça me dépasse de l'autre
côté peut-être
moi je vais pas venir risquer parce que
en général quand je donne un pronostic
ça va dans le sens contraire on va dire
qualification du Bayern Munich comme ça
peut-être on espère du Paris
Saint-Germain parler football dans un
instant mais on va prendre le large tout
de suite nickel avec la Route du Rhum
c'est la course en solitaire qui a été
décalé on le disait tout à l'heure à
cause de mauvaises conditions météo le
départ de cette course a été décalé donc
de dimanche à mercredi 14h15 de
yvelinois seront en course dans la
classe IMOCA le versaillais Eric Bellion
et le
rembolitain Louis Burton qu'on aura
peut-être l'occasion d'interviewer dans
les prochaines heures avant son départ
il est très pris il est sur des briefing
en ce moment météo donc on ne peut pas
l'avoir malheureusement ce soir
peut-être demain
prendre le départ sur la Route du Rhum
ce mercredi
Eric Bellion le versaillé sera engagé
sur cette édition 2022 dans la catégorie
IMOCA le navigateur de 46 ans espèrent
réaliser une belle performance pour se
préparer pour le futur Vendée Globe on
écoute son interview express
[Applaudissements]
mon objectif c'est d'être parmi les
meilleurs donc c'est de faire de mon
mieux pour aller le plus vite possible
la Route du Rhum c'est un bateau c'est
une course qui est pas trop faite pour
les bateaux à dérive droite mais bon on
n'est pas à l'abri de bonne condition
climatiques qui nous font aller vite au
début donc moi mon objectif c'est d'être
parmi les meilleurs et donner le maximum
de ce que j'ai ça ça change jamais donc
je on est trois acteurs il y a l'océan
il y a mon bateau il y a moi et si tous
les trois ben on travaille bien en
harmonie ça devrait bien le faire
[Musique]
le départ est vraiment difficile on peut
avoir une tempête à passer c'est souvent
c'est le mois de novembre donc c'est les
tempêtes hivernales dans l'Atlantique
donc d'abord il faut passer cette
tempête il faut passer sous le cap de
sous la latitude de Lisbonne et là après
on touche les alizés c'est beaucoup plus
simple même si on est toujours pas
arrivé parce que les alizés peuvent être
compliqués notamment le matin enlever du
soleil et on part des grains très très
puissants mais la grosse difficulté
c'est passé l'hiver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai un bateau mythique c'est Hubert qui
a gagné le Vendée Globe en 2007-2008 il
vient le bateau de Jean Le Cam à qui
j'ai loué le bateau et j'adore mon
bateau en sortant super bien et je pense
que je vais être très triste de le
rendre à Jean Lecam après l'arrivée de
la Route du Rhum
[Applaudissements]
voilà pour cette Route du Rhum dont le
départ je disais était décalé à mercredi
à 14h15 en raison des mauvaises
conditions climatiques Michael on va
revenir aussi sur les autres résultats
du week-end dans les Yvelines et parler
notamment de football oui et par une
très belle performance celle de
Versailles en National les joueurs de la
cité royale se sont imposés 1 à 0 sur la
pelouse de Châteauroux se vend
l'histoire avec une réalisation signée
au monde dit prunier avec ce résultat le
FC Versailles se retrouve à la deuxième
place du classement avec 19 points
engranger en 11 journée le prochain
match des versaillers est programmé ce
vendredi 11 novembre contre le Stade
briochin dernier a du classement très
bonne période pour Versailles d'où cette
invention un peu surprenante Versailles
qui vient de perdre son entraîneur la
nouvelle est tombée ce lundi c'est la
petite bombe du jour on peut le dire
l'entraîneur de l'équipe du FC
Versailles Youssef chibi et mise à pied
à titre conservatoire le club a annoncé
aujourd'hui dans un communiqué officiel
sans préciser les raisons de sa mise à
pied coach l'équipe depuis juillet 2014
et artisans de la progression du club
jusqu'en national il pouvez aussi
emmener le club en demi-finale de la
Coupe de France l'année dernière on s'en
souvient tous Vincent et woman et
l'ensemble du staff actuel prennent en
charge l'équipe pour la réception du
Stade de briochin ce sera donc ce
vendredi 11 novembre pour une nouvelle
journée dans le championnat de National
on va descente d'un étage et parler du
championnat national de en football en 2
Poissy a perdu ce weekend sur le terrain
de Châteaubriant à l'occasion de la 9e
journée du championnat alors qu'ils
avaient à marqué en premier par Konaté
dès la troisième minute les pissacées se
sont finalement qui est de 1 à la 87e
minute au classement l'as Poissy est à
la troisième place du championnat à 5
points du leader le Racing Club de
France malheureusement une fin de
parcours en rugby c'est bien triste
Emily Boulard ne sera pas championne du
monde cette année livelinois institut là
avec l'équipe de France a perdu avec ses
coéquipières ce samedi à Auckland en
demi-finale de la Coupe du monde face au
néo-zélandaise le score est terrible 25
à 24 les Françaises ont raté une
pénalité à une minute de la fin la
joueuse yvelinoise disputera ce samedi
face au Canada le match pour la à 3e
place sera débriefer un cette
compétition avec elle elle qui avait été
notamment MVP du quart de finale face à
l'Italie Emily Boulard du rugby masculin
cette fois-ci et on parle du championnat
de fédéral 2 belle performance de
Versailles cette fois-ci en rugby a
décidément Versailles est une ville de
sport et surtout il y a de bons
résultats les joueurs de la cité royale
se sont imposés à 29 à 24 à domicile
face à Boulogne-Billancourt ce résultat
permet au versaillé d'occuper la 8e
place du championnat prochain match ce
dimanche 13 novembre sur le terrain de
Courbevoie il y a un autre club yvelin
dans cette boule de fédéral 2 alors 6
Versailles a gagné plaisir c'est incliné
26 à 21 sur son terrain face à
Courbevoie dans un match disputé on
regarde le résumé du match un reportage
de Nicolas dandry et Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude
c'est une défaite avec un goût amer pour
plaisir les jaunes et bleu se sont
inclinés 26 à 21 face à Courbevoie il y
avait la place pour les plaisirsois
campés devant l'embut de la adversaire
les hommes de Sébastien ronali n'ont
jamais réussi à franchir la ligne dans
les dernières minutes de la rencontre
pour arracher la victoire je sais pas le
nombre de fautes mais je pense qu'il y
en a bien une dizaine de pénalités
d'affilée à 5 mètres de la ligne donc on
verra tout ça la vidéo mais bon c'est
sur un cumul de foot comme ça je
comprends même pas comment il y a pas
essayé de tonalité comment il y a pas
plusieurs cartons bon enfin vraiment
voilà on est très très très déçu
effectivement par rapport à ça tout
avait pourtant bien commencé pour
plaisir après 20 minutes de jeu les
plaisirs amènent 14 à 3
[Musique]
Courbevoie recolle au score en
inscrivant un premier essai mais avant
le retour au vestiaire les aiguilles
noires reprennent le large à la mi-temps
plaisir prend de l'avance 21 à 13
revigorer avec plus de maîtrise
Courbevoie réussie son début de seconde
période en 20 minutes les visiteurs
virent en tête 21 à 26
le score restera inchangé jusqu'à la fin
de la rencontre peut-être qu'on se
trouve une fois eu deux défensivement
justement sur sur le début de cette
deuxième mi-temps ils reviennent dans le
match et du coup bon bah voilà ils sont
en confiance et nous après on est obligé
de courir courir sur le score à la fin
et voilà quoi c'est peut-être en terme
de la deuxième là qui est avec son
excellent début de saison plaisir
conserve la deuxième place au classement
malgré cette défaite les plaisirs rois
prennent un point de bonus défensif
prochain match prévu ce dimanche 13
novembre à Domont
plaisir est donc en bonne position pour
terminer dans le top 5 du classement
mais il faudra rester quand même
concentré jusqu'à la fin rester
concentré on l'espère pour pour
peut-être atteindre ces phases finales
dans le championnat de Fédérale 2 un mot
de handball à présent après le rugby le
handball dans le championnat de National
3 plaisirs les classes connus la défaite
ce weekend les hommes de Benjamin
modeste se sont inclinés 30 à 25 sur
leur temps contre Paris Sport Club une
défaite plutôt logique face solidaire du
classement au classement justement les
plaisirs les clés dans le milieu du
classement à la sixième place mais c'est
très serré merci Michael pour toutes ces
précisions on va parler encore un peu de
sport et de cyclisme plus précisément
avec le huitième Grand Prix de Vélizy
qui était organisé ce dimanche au
programme vitesse kering scratch course
au point en Vélodrome national de 50 ans
en Yvelines vous avez notamment consacré
un reportage sur ce Grand Prix avec les
images bien sûr de Patrick Jack Denix
Méda au bout de l'effort Nathan dauphin
termine deuxième sur cette course au
point organisée dans le cadre du Grand
Prix de Vélizy une compétition à
domicile pour cette ini montant dans ce
vélo de route nationale de 50 ans en
Yvelines c'est la première de l'année
c'est pour voir un peu les adversaires
par rapport à moi et je m'étais fixé un
podium bon bah j'ai réussi donc je suis
bien content au total ils étaient 124
engagés sur cette 8e édition du Grand
Prix de vélizyn compétition nationale
avec des KDD juniors et des élites un
concept imaginé en 2015 par le C Vélizy
78 c'est une une tradition que de
vouloir organiser des épreuves surpiste
il n'y en a très peu d'organiser en
Île-de-France et nous on marque un point
d'honneur donc à organiser chaque année
le Grand Prix de Vélizy mais également
au minimum un championnat
d'Île-de-France cette année 30 féminine
était inscrite pour ce rendez-vous une
première parmi les têtes d'affiches ont
retrouvé notamment Julie Michaud
quatrième des championnats d'Europe
élite en vitesse par équipe et 5e par
équipe au Championnat du Monde 2022 sur
ce vélo Drôme mon entraîneur m'a dit
Julie prend du plaisir
et pour vous dire je fais même
l'endurance aujourd'hui alors que ça
fait très longtemps que j'ai pas fait
d'endurance et donc c'est vraiment pour
m'amuser et me remettre dans le dans
l'ambiance Julie Michaud rejoint la
longue liste des membres de l'équipe de
France ayant participé à la compétition
actuellement tous les pistes
internationaux tricolore ont couru le
Grand Prix de Vélizy un rendez-vous qui
reviendra l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition
[Musique]
chaque semaine retrouvez le Vy P sur TV
78 very linoise personne est consacrée
aux personnalités du territoire
yvelinois focus cette fois-ci non pas
sur une personne mais sur une émission
l'antisèche c'est le rendez-vous
culturel qui vous propose d'apprendre
tout en s'amusant c'est chaque mercredi
de 20h à 21h sur les ondes de marmite FM
88.4 l'équipe de bénévoles entamé depuis
la rentrée ça septième saison regarder
un extrait de l'émission l'émission que
personne ne sèche ça c'est le slogan le
concept de l'émission C'est un
rendez-vous décalé apprendre tout en
s'amusant c'est ça l'idée avec de la
bonne humeur c'est le maître mot oui
c'est ça l'idée l'idée c'est on va
apprendre on va passer enfin on va on va
décompresser voilà on va se faire une
petite soupape de décompression le
mercredi soir entre 20h et 21h on va
découvrir des artistes locaux on va
apprendre plein de choses sur la culture
et surtout je pense qu'on va apprendre
des choses qu'on entend pas partout dans
les médias et voilà et c'est ça l'idée
c'est de passer un bon moment et de
retenir des choses qu'on peut raconter
par exemple le lendemain la machine à
café
dans un reportage qu'on avait consacré à
l'émission antisèche l'idée c'est de
poser son cerveau est-ce que tu peux
préciser voilà d'emblée d'emblée on
commence avec avec les petits dossiers
mais c'est quoi l'idée poser son cerveau
c'est à dire déconnecter comme le disait
comme le disait Julien et voilà
apprendre en s'amusant c'est c'est
complètement ça c'est à dire que ce que
je voulais dire par là c'est qu'en fait
on apprend mais en fait on sent même pas
compte qu'on qu'on apprend c'est
vraiment c'est du divertissement c'est
on s'amuse en fait tout simplement
émission vypr retrouvé en intégralité
sur TV 78 et TV 78.com derrière
l'antisèche d'ailleurs on le disait joli
prod l'association organise une nouvelle
édition de sa jolie soirée concert c'est
samedi 12 novembre au Théâtre de 50 ans
en Yvelines au programme 3 concerts rap
par des groupes et artistes des Yvelines
et de 50 ans en Yvelines le début est
fixé à 20h30 tarif de 10 euros info et
billetterie sur le site internet de
jolies prod avant de vous laisser on
refait un dernier point sur la météo
[Musique]
ce mardi 8 novembre jour de la saint
Geoffroy y aura des éclaircies dans la
matinée yvelinoise compter 12 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et Versailles 11
degrés à Rambouillet l'après-midi il
pourrait y avoir quelques averses côté
température 14 degrés à Rambouillet 15
degrés à Versailles ou dans et
Mantes-la-Jolie voilà c'est la fin du 7
8 merci de votre fidélité on se retrouve
dès demain pour une nouvelle émission
belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]